twenty-eight-year-old frankeski flamis
is more than seven thousand kilometers
from home
with ten-month-old maria in tow she
sells sweets for coins so that she can
feed her baby and hopefully gather
enough to rent a room tonight
that way they won't have to sleep
outdoors in the freezing cold
she arrived from venezuela two weeks ago
after crossing the atacama desert and
entered chile as an undocumented migrant
like hundreds of thousands of her
compatriots
a bolivian guy helped us cross the
border at night we had to crawl so no
one would see us we passed fences and
trenches and we couldn't make noise the
children couldn't cry so the police
wouldn't hear us
[Music]
frankeski is among hundreds of thousands
who've traveled to chile seeking a
better life
while tens of thousands of central
american haitian and cuban migrants
attempt to cross into the united states
every day
but the migration crisis in the americas
no longer flows exclusively from south
to north according to united nations
nearly 6 million venezuelans have
migrated to escape hardships at home
with the majority heading south
especially to colombia peru argentina
and chile
migration has increased by 66 percent in
the last decade impacting public
services and resources in the recipient
countries
they have the legitimate right and the
responsibility to guarantee stability
and conditions that create well-being
for migrants to ensure that the
irregular influx of migrants doesn't
produce poverty human trafficking and
exploitation
chile's former foreign minister says
it's now a major regional challenge
sharing the burden i think is
fundamental that happened in europe it
wasn't easy they arrived a system of
quotas
of
migrants
and i think something similar could be
explored at least in the americas
the un's economic commission for latin
america and the caribbean has presented
a marshall plan for central america that
requires funding especially from the
united states
u.s president joe biden had offered 4
billion dollars to create better jobs
and safety but so far the money has only
trickled in
we can't confront migration only with
block borders severe laws or wall and
police we need well-being security and
peace in the countries where migration
originates
it's hoped that regional cooperation to
tackle the phenomena will be the main
theme at the upcoming summit of the
americas in los angeles
even with the priorities of the united
states now focused elsewhere to see a
newman al jazeera santiago